By the way, have either of you seen the latest Batman movie?
Yeah, I saw it.
How did you like the movie?
Well, I didn't like it all that much.
Really? Why not? I loved it!
I thought the special effects weren't that good,...
...and I was really disappointed with the storyline.
No kidding! I was on the edge of my seat right up until the end.
How about you, Susie, have you seen it?
Yes, I liked it very much, but I'm definitely the wrong person to ask about Batman.
Oh? Why's that?
I'm not into superhero movies at all.
To be honest, science fiction movies aren't my thing.
Well, I guess we can disagree on that, then.
I guess so.
But at least we do agree on tonight's movie.